si quand le planter
c'était
une micropousse et ça pousse à une
vitesse exponentielle le maire de
l'arrondissement de Rosemont la petite
patrie est fière de nous montrer les
arbustes d'une de ces micro-forêts
situés dans le parc père market une
microforest un concept qui a été
développé au Japon qui est un concept où
on plante des toutes petites pousses
d'armes très proche des zones des autres
dans l'espoir dans l'espoir que Dieu se
fasse compétition et qu'ils aient une
croissance très rapide pour absorber
énormément de carbone
l'arrondissement d'Outremont vient aussi
d'aménager une première micro forêt
urbaine dans un parc à l'intersection de
la côte Sainte-Catherine et de la côte
du Vésinet nous mettons ici sur un
terrain en pente ça va limiter l'érosion
de la pente par les racines qui vont
pousser aussi c'est un ça va créer une
zone tampon avec coaching Catherine pour
le bruit ça va être un poumon aussi pour
la région parce que une mini forêt capte
beaucoup plus de carbone le CO2 que des
arbres individuellement la ville
investit dans des microforets mais aussi
dans la plantation d'arbres l'an dernier
Montréal a planté plus de 40 milliards
et souhaite que la population suivent
son exemple pour moi ce sont les
entreprises les institutions les
citoyens qui peuvent aussi planter dans
leur cours arrière ou leur inter un
arbre c'est aussi un moyen de faire face
aux changements climatique de contrer
des sécheresses et des vagues de chaleur
les arbres non seulement vont produire
de l'ombre vont produire également de
l'humidité dans l'air ils vont
évapotranspirer et mettre la vapeur
d'eau dans l'air ils vont également nous
prémunir contre les vents très forts
difficiles d'être contre la nature et la
beauté des arbres même en ville
dans le bois
quand tu pars sur une rue pendant c'est
tellement laid dégradé alors la nature
amène une beauté à la ville ici Jacques
Bissonnière Radio-Canada Montréal